Welcome back to human emotion.
Today we'll be,
uh,
entering our second component of emotion and cognition and today focusing on the
concept of emotional intelligence.
And I'm particularly excited to have a very special guest lecture today,
a world renowned expert on the topic,
Dr Marc Brackett.
So our roadmap today on emotion cognition part two will go as follows.
We'll start with our guests lecture on emotional intelligence,
followed by takeaway questions corresponding to the guest lecture today and
concluding with our expert interview.
So I'm going to start here by briefly introducing our special guest lecture
today,
who's going to speak with us on emotional intelligence.
So today we have Dr Marc Brackett speaking with us.
Mark Brackett is the director of the Yale Center for emotional intelligence and
he's also a research scientist in psychology and faculty fellow in the Edwards
teglar center in child development and social policy at Yale University.
Dr Bracket is the author of 90 scholarly publications and the developer have to
university courses on emotional intelligence.
He's also the co creator of the ruler approach to social and emotional learning.
Um,
ruler fosters the development of social and emotional skills.
And children from kindergarten through high school as well as school leaders,
teachers,
staff,
and families.
Over 500,000 students in hundreds of schools throughout the world have benefited
from ruler.
So I'm very excited today to have Dr Marc Brackett with us today to share his
expertise on emotional intelligence.
So the topic of my presentation is emotional intelligence.
And uh,
again,
my name is Marc Brackett,
the director of the Yale Center for emotional intelligence.
Let me give you an overview of my presentation before I begin.
First,
what I'd like to do is share with you sort of the traditional versus the modern
view of emotions.
Then we'll talk about the foundations of emotional intelligence.
I'll give you a brief history of this idea of emotional intelligence.
Then we'll talk about how do you measure emotional intelligence.
Following that,
we'll think about how does our,
what is emotion intelligence predict about a person's everyday life?
And then I'll talk to you about where most of my work lives these days,
which is how do you create emotionally intelligent the schools?
And then we'll end with what we believe is the future of emotional intelligence.
As you can see from this slide,
uh,
historically the idea of an emotional intelligence would be an oxymoron.
As a matter of fact,
it was quite interesting about,
uh,
about two weeks ago,
I was coming back from a trip and I was in a taxi coming back from the airport
and the taxi driver asked me,
so what do you do when I said,
I studied this concept of emotional intelligence?
And he said to me,
that sounds like an oxymoron.
And too many people,
emotional intelligence would be an oxymoron because as you can see from the
slide historic Lee,
uh,
in the ancient Greece,
people would say things like,
rule your feelings less.
They'll rule you even in psychology and education,
uh,
experts said that emotions cause a complete loss of cerebral control and no
trace of conscious purpose.
So the idea of an emotional intelligence,
uh,
would be an oxymoron,
at least back in the early 19 hundreds.
Yeah,
a very different view exists these days.
Abundant research has not been conducted on the role of emotions and why
emotions drive for primary aspects of our everyday life.
The first is that emotions drive attention,
memory and learning.
Think about it,
if you're a student in school and you're board,
how will you be present in that classroom?
What will happen is that your mind will be distracted and you will be thinking
about all the things you want to do over the weekend versus being engaged in the
learning process.
The second is that emotions drive much of our everyday decisions.
How many of us have made a bad decision?
And we think it's our rational side that is controlling that,
but oftentimes it's an emotional component.
The third is relationship quality.
And I always ask people,
how many of you like to be around somebody who's angry and disgruntled all the
time?
And typically most people try to stay away from people who act like that because
we,
they're unpredictable.
Uh,
we don't like to be around people who generate a lot of negative emotions.
And finally,
another area of research that has gone,
gotten a lot of attention is how emotions drive much of our mental health and
physical health.
When we think about what most people seek treatment for,
such as anxiety and depression,
we think about how those are disorders for many parts are for much part in
emotion regulation.
Yeah.
So in 1990 we were very lucky here at Yale,
Peter Salivate,
the now president of the university and my doctoral adviser John Mayer,
define the idea or the concept of emotional intelligence and where they define
emotional intelligence as is the ability to monitor one's own and other's
feelings,
to discriminate among them and to use this information to guide one's thinking
and action.
And this was a unique time in history back in 1990 because up until the late
seventies and eighties people were kind of studying emotions in disparate ways.
So what that means is that there were individuals studying how emotions drive
attention and memory and they were in their own little camp.
There were developmental psychologist studying how children's emotional
understanding develops over time and with age.
There were other studying emotion regulation and there were more at is really
trying to understand how emotion perception exists.
Is it universal?
Do people read faces the same way across different cultures.
But what Peter and Jack did was they saw that there are these different domains
of what people do with their emotional life.
And they asserted that there were individual differences,
that some people were better or worse at reading facial expressions.
Some people were better or worse that are regulating emotions.
And in that year they also provided the first empirical study that it could be
measured like a traditional intelligence.
Now,
many of you probably heard of the term emotional intelligence through with
popularization.
And in 1995 Dan Goleman wrote the bestselling pop psychology book ever written
on the topic of emotional intelligence.
And that book has now sold millions of copies and has been translated into I
think,
30 languages.
One thing that Dan did do was broaden the definition of emotional intelligence
for the popular audience,
but you also made some pretty substantial claims that EEQ matters more than Iq,
that it's the best predictor of success in life.
And in many ways that,
uh,
those claims were far outreach,
the empirical investigations that had been done at the time,
yet the timing was right.
There was lots of going on in America.
Uh,
this was post the bell curve where people were very sort of nervous about what
it means to be intelligent and that intelligent was this meant non malleable
idea or construct.
And there was also a lot of violence in schools.
And what emotional intelligence did was promised that there was another way to
be smart and that perhaps this way of being smart mattered more than general
intelligence
in 1997 after all the popularization,
uh,
Marin's hell every redefine emotional intelligence and really broke it down into
its four basic parts.
And as you can see from our slide here,
they argued that emotional intelligence is the ability to perceive a praise and
express your emotion,
to understand emotion and emotional knowledge,
to access in generate feelings when they facilitate thought and to regulate
emotions in a way that assists thought.
So they came up with,
they call their four branch model of emotional intelligence.
Now,
many people are curious,
you know,
how do you measure this thing called emotional intelligence?
And what we've learned over the years is that people are trying to measure it
with three different measurement tools.
The first is self report.
You can ask someone directly,
do you read facial expressions?
Well,
how skilled are you at regulating your emotions?
Can also ask people who know you well for example,
you can ask your family and your friends are in a workplace.
You might ask your direct reports or the person you report to and figure out or
learn what they think about your emotional intelligence.
The third way is what we call performance assessment tools of emotional
intelligence and our laboratory.
We've really focused on that because the gold standard for measuring and
intelligence is using performance measures.
We've really focused on measuring emotional intelligence of the set of mental
abilities.
So we do is we ask people to solve emotional in problems and we look at how they
score on such task by comparing them to different criteria.
The primary criteria that we use,
our expert consensus course where we bring in experts from different domains of
emotion research and we get their expert opinions about what um,
the answer is for a particular question.
Okay.
Now as you can see here,
we've studied the relationship between different types of emotional intelligence
measures and what we've learned is that performance measures of emotional
intelligence are related to but not redundant with personality well being in
general intelligence.
So that tells us is that emotional intelligence is this new construct that
explains variance above and beyond existing personality variables like the big
five or general intelligence.
Well we've also shown is that self report measures of emotional intelligence do
not correlate at all with ability measures.
Our performance assessment tools and this diagram here on the right demonstrates
that.
So what we have here,
our people's performance scores taking a the bottom 25th,
the second,
the third and the fourth quartile.
And these lines in the middle are all self report measures of emotional
intelligence.
And what you can see is that most people think that they're above average on
emotional intelligence,
which is just like most people believe they are in general intelligence and that
there seems to be no relationship between performance assessment tools and self
report measures.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it,
it makes me think oftentimes when I teach psychology,
uh,
to undergraduates,
I have them look at each other and I say,
how much smarter do you think you are than the person next to you?
And for some reason 80% of my students think they're smarter than the person
next to them.
So,
uh,
generally what we're saying is that you can't measure an intelligence by asking
people what they think about their intelligence.
You have to know what their actual score is or at least tested in a way that's
more objective.
Yeah.
So in some about measurement,
we know that self knowledge is quite limited in the domain of emotional
intelligence as it is in other domains.
As you can see,
even in other domains such as intelligence or attractiveness,
people just don't know how to rate themselves,
you know,
a model and may think,
well,
this model is even more beautiful than I am.
Or someone who I say,
well,
it's gotta be somebody who's smarter than I am.
So what we do in our laboratory is really focused on how do you measure
emotional intelligence as a set of mental abilities.
Now,
many of us want to know what does emotional intelligence predict about a
person's life?
And as you can see from this slide,
the left column a,
these are mostly adolescents and middle schools and high schools in this
particular research,
less skilled.
Okay.
Is the column on the left more skilled is the column on the right.
And these are not just their studies that we've done in our laboratory,
but studies from different labs across the United States and even the world.
And in general,
what you see is that children or adolescents who are less skilled in these
abilities and emotional intelligence tend to live quite different lives than
those who are more skilled.
Yeah.
Even in business.
And teaching applications.
You can see outcomes of being emotionally intelligent,
uh,
are quite staggering.
Higher customer service ratings enhance expressiveness and empathy,
greater social support from colleagues,
greater job satisfaction there.
Re,
um,
the report of more positive emotions at work.
It's a matter of fact that did one study recently in Connecticut with a about
100 managers and I asked it does 100 managed to take our performance tests of
emotional intelligence?
And they had the CEO,
the CFO,
and the COO of the organization rate them on different leadership competencies.
And I asked one extra question,
which was,
if you were to leave this company tomorrow,
what would you do to take this person with you?
And what we showed was that the individuals are these managers who had the
highest scores on our test of emotion intelligence were rated by the top
executives of that organization as the ones who they would fight to take with
them.
So people just want to be around people who are more emotionally intelligent.
Okay.
Now as I said earlier,
the focus of my research really has been in school systems.
How do you create emotional intelligent organizations and in particular schools,
what we know is that schools have changed.
The function of schools have changed.
A traditional training for teachers and leaders has neglected emotional
intelligence instruction for decades or forever.
Uh,
the nature of teaching and leading has changed is more burnout.
There's larger classrooms.
We have standardized testing and the prevalence of social emotional problems in
schools has really risen.
And as you can see from this list,
from absenteeism to drop to a bullying.
Yeah.
Now the approach that we've created in schools,
we call ruler and roller stands for five key skills.
And those are embedded in the theory of emotional intelligence.
The first is recognizing emotion.
The second is understanding.
The third is labeling,
expressing,
regulating.
So we do a little game with it.
It's recognizing emotion,
understanding emotion,
a labeling,
emotion,
expressing emotion and regulating emotion.
Let me take you through those skills really quickly.
The first is recognizing emotion,
identifying emotion and face and posture,
gesture,
voice in physiology.
So it's not just about recognizing emotions and the face,
it's listening to someone's voice.
It is paying attention to their body posture.
It is looking at their gestures.
Yeah.
The understanding of emotion gets more complex because we're trying to think
here about the causes and the consequences of emotion.
How do our emotions affect our attention,
our thinking,
our decisions,
and our behavior.
So different moods,
for example,
are associated with different types of thinking and judgment and decision
making.
For example,
if you're a very high energy and pleasant,
it's better for brainstorming.
Whereas if you're a slightly lower in energy and slightly unpleasant,
it might be better at critical thinking,
for example,
or proofing of paper.
If you're a student labeling emotion,
it has to do with that sophisticated vocabulary that we want to teach your
children and adults to use when talking about their feelings.
States,
we know that most people have two words in there in the English language to
describe how they're feeling.
Fine.
Okay.
Well when children learn ruler,
they started saying,
well,
I feel elated.
I'm feeling a bit despair.
Um,
I'm not nervous.
I'm actually apprehensive.
I'm not just calm.
I'm feeling serene.
So we help children really differentiate their emotional experience because what
we believe is that when children can name it,
they're going to be more skilled at taming it.
By creating or giving children the language to describe their emotional states,
what we're able to do is help them create a mental model of what that emotional
experience is like and in turn,
give them the strategies they need to help them regulate it.
Expressing emotion is next.
I always joke around with people and say,
how many of you know someone who is a socially inappropriate and everybody seems
to raise their hand because not many of us are taught about how to express our
emotions the right time with the right place.
You know,
I remember vividly when I was a graduate student,
I was with a colleague of mine who was just very down about something going on
and one of our mentors came in the room.
He just started screaming,
you're not going to believe when I did this weekend.
Just not paying attention to the cues and not knowing that it wasn't the right
time or place to really talk about all the great things that happened over her
weekend,
that we're really focusing on helping this young woman manage her emotions.
It's also has to do with culture.
Uh,
most of our schools these days are multicultural.
So the rules for emotion very is a function of culture.
My other careers I teach martial arts and had been to Korea a lot and what we've
learned in Korea is that,
you know,
eye gaze means something different than eye gaze here or in New York City.
Um,
the uh,
the rules about how much you share about your own emotions varies as a function
of culture.
So we want to do is make schools cultural literate about emotion as well.
And the final r and ruler is regulating emotions and this skill focus
specifically on the knowledge and strategies that we use to prevent,
reduce an issue,
maintain or enhance our emotions.
And the way we think about emotion regulation in schools and in life in general
is that we have goals and we have strategies.
So when we're experiencing an emotion,
what we want to do is first think about,
do I want to prevent this feeling from occurring?
So how many of you have anticipated going to a relatives house that you just
dreaded going to and you can think,
I'll kind of gotta be so uptight in this house or this person with this person.
So what do you do to prepare for that or prevent the negative emotion?
Obviously we need to reduce those ones that get us unexpectedly.
Um,
we also have to be at an initiate emotions.
So as a teacher in particular,
we want to teach teachers how to create an emotion so that the learning
experience can be more engaging.
Oftentimes we want to maintain or emotions.
Uh,
this is really getting at,
you know,
we're feeling pleasant.
Then we go home or we go to a party or go to our friend's house and the dreams
dealers come in and try to sort of steal us of our pleasant emotions.
And what do we do to maintain those positive feelings?
And of course,
since then,
we have to just boost the energy and enhance emotions.
So rulers theory of change is um,
very straightforward.
What we argue is that you have our approach,
which is the intervention and then the strategies are we,
as I say,
train everybody with a face from leaders to teachers and staff to classroom
curriculum,
getting families involved.
Very importantly,
we have what we call our proximal outcomes.
Our goal here is that what we want to do is both develop the individual skills
of the student,
the teacher,
the leader of the family member,
but also create a common language and a community where the climate is
emotionally healthy.
And so taking the systems approach and this individual difference approach and
combining them is really our mechanism for change.
And what we now know from our research is that when you do develop the
individual skills and you change the climate,
you can get the outcomes that you're interested from academic achievement,
going up to relationship,
becoming better to better mental and physical health.
Very quickly when I want to do is share with you the methods that we use to
create an emotionally intelligent school system.
The first tool is called the charter.
So we try to work with schools to get rid of their rules and help them think
about how students and teachers want to feel.
So instead of saying,
can't run the hallways,
keep your hands to yourself.
We ask kids to think about and talk about the feelings that they want to have
each day when they come into school.
Then we ask them to consider the behaviors that are necessary for those emotions
to come alive.
And finally,
knowing that conflict is just part of life,
we ask students to think critically about what are the things that they would
like to do to prevent conflict and to manage it when it occurs.
And this becomes what we call the emotional literacy charter.
The second tool is called the mood meter.
And as I mentioned earlier,
emotions drive much of our thinking and decision making.
So this tool is helping children and adults learn about their emotions.
There are two axes,
the pleasantness and the energy access,
and then that those axes break up into four quadrants.
The yellow,
the red,
the blue,
and the green.
So yellow is positive emotions,
which goes from maybe happy to ecstatic red would be the anxiety and anger
family,
which maybe peeve too enraged or uneasy too panicky.
Uh,
the blue would go from sad to depressed and the green from just calm to bliss or
serene.
So in with the mood meter,
what we do is teach children how to build their vocabulary.
We teach them how to develop strategies to help shift their moods from different
quadrants to other quadrants.
The third tool is we call them at a moment and um,
you know,
the men and women is a special tool because,
uh,
the idea of this fourth step,
which we call the best self,
came out of many conversations with my colleague Robin Stern,
but also out of a,
an article that was written here at Yale about the course that I taught a few
years ago.
And this one student of mine wrote a court,
wrote an article and it was called the feelings master.
And I remember,
you know,
being a little embarrassed by it,
but also trying to think what does a head is a feeling of the master at live his
life.
So when I'd walk around campus,
I think it has the feelings master walk,
you know,
feelings,
master of walks with good posture.
Then I'd be having meetings with my students,
maybe one which would be kind of like uncomfortable at the student was kind of
whining and it's there.
How does the feelings master react to the whining student?
And what I started realizing is that to be skilled and emotion regulation,
what we want to do is have motivation to be skilled.
So the four or the six steps of the Meta moment is teaching people that
something happens.
Knowing your triggers,
sensing how those triggers are affecting your thoughts,
your physiology,
even your expressive behavior,
knowing that when you're activated tried to stop as early as possible in that
intensity building part of it.
Take that breath to activate your parasympathetic nervous system so you can be
clear.
Then we teach children and adults to activate their best self.
So what does the ideal teacher doing this situation?
What does the ideal student doing this situation?
And by activating that best self,
what we know and believe is that you will choose more adaptive and healthy
strategies to downregulate or change your emotional state.
And hopefully that will then lead you to a successful interaction.
Finally,
what we know is that not all of us are skilled at taking them on a moments.
And many of us,
even myself included,
sometimes know that the Meta moment is the right thing to do.
But of course make that bad decision and say the unpleasant thing or the hurtful
thing to someone and then we have to problem solve.
So the blueprint is now getting away from just me and talking about the we in
emotion regulation that what happened is there was a problem between the two of
us.
Maybe I misread you,
maybe I sort of wasn't really paying attention.
Uh,
and it asked the individual to really break down their inexperience and the
other person's experience.
So the goal of the blueprint is really to help build empathy and perspective
taking by considering not only how did you feel,
but how do the other person feel.
Not only just what causes your feelings,
but what might have caused the other person,
how did the other person regulate?
And oftentimes when we complete the blueprint,
we realize that we have,
uh,
we don't have enough information and,
we may have made some assumptions about the other person and that we need to
further investigate so that we can have clarity and resolve the conflict
creative land effectively.
To finalize my presentation,
what we've learned from our work on ruler in schools,
we've now done,
uh,
a number of experiments,
one very large randomized control trial and 66 schools in the New York area.
What we're showing is that schools that decide to take this approach on
seriously look different.
Um,
they have students who report less anxiety and depression,
students who manage their emotions more effectively,
that are better problem solvers.
And as you can see many positive gains even in academic performance.
And we've also shown that not only do we help the individuals develop their
skills,
but what we also can do is change the climate and culture of classrooms.
They're more engaging as students are more connected,
they experience more positive emotions in school.
And knowing that the experience of positive emotions and engagement is the
predictor of academic success.
That makes us pretty happy with the findings.
Lastly,
we're,
you know,
in the very beginning stages of our understanding of this concept of emotional
intelligence,
if you make the comparison to General Intelligence,
uh,
you know,
that was the fine well over a hundred years ago when people had been trying to
measure and general intelligence for decades,
a hundred years or more emotional intelligence is only defined in 1990 redefine
in 1997.
And so we have about 2025 years of research to unpack this complex component of
emotional intelligence,
these recognizing emotion skills and understanding,
labeling,
expressing and regulating.
So the future of emotional intelligence,
I believe we'll continue to build new performance measures where we start
breaking down the crystallized versus a fluid aspects of emotional intelligence.
Well,
we'll also do is study how emotional intelligence develops,
including the biological and environmental influences and gender differences,
which have been apparent from the beginning of our research on emotional
intelligence.
And finally,
I think most people are interested in emotional intelligence because they want
to know what it can do for them.
How can it improve their lives?
So much of our research in the future,
we'll focus on what does it mean to be an emotionally intelligent person?
How does it influence my relationships?
How does it influence my mental health and how does it influence my performance
both at school and at work?
So that's concludes my presentation on emotion intelligence.
So thanks for fantastic guests,
lecture from Doctor Mark Brackett on emotional intelligence.
So now we're going to do a segue to our takeaway questions that correspond to
this really fantastic guest lecture from today.
So the takeaway questions,
these kind of correspond to the main points you want to glean from this guest
lecture you had.
Stay from Dr Marc Brackett.
The first really focuses on how would you define what emotional intelligence is.
Second,
what are the different ways that you can systematically try to measure emotional
intelligence?
And finally,
what does the ruler approach discussed today stand for and how would you
describe each of its component parts?
Yeah,
no,
I just want to conclude then with our expert interview today and for our expert
interview today.
This is part of our experts and emotion interview series.
And today we'll have a doctor Derek is [inaudible],
an associate professor of psychology at northeastern university who'll be
speaking with us on emotion intention.
So he received his phd from the University of Pennsylvania working with Dr.
Martin Seligman and his Ba from Stanford University working with Dr Laura
Carstensen.
Doctors Sakowitz.
This research interests lie at the intersection of the tension and emotion,
particularly among older adults.
He's received numerous honors,
including the American Psychological Association Early Career Award from
division 20 the Margaret m and Paul,
the Balts Foundation Award and behavioral and Social Gerontology for outstanding
early career contributions from the chair Gerontological Society of America,
as well as several graduate mentoring and teaching awards.
His research has been funded by grants from the NIH and doctor Zach Woods has
served on the editorial boards of several renowned journals,
including psychology and aging emotion,
as well as the Journal of personality and social psychology.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Derek is
[inaudible].